[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست
1600 جندي هيعيش لو بس الرساله وصلت في
الوقت المناسب جنديين قدامهم اقل من 24
ساعه علشان يوصلوا الرساله في وقت فيه
الجيش الالماني في قمه قوته ايه اللي
هيحصل ويا ترى هيقدروا يوصلوا الرساله دي
في ميعادها ده اللي بيحكي عنه فيلم 19 او
1917 فاهلا بيك في حلقه جديده من بودكا
للافلام والنهارده هاخدك في رحله لما وراء
احداث الحرب في
1917 احنا دلوقتي يوم 6 ابريل سنه 1917
بنشوف جنديين نايمين في سلام وبيجيلهم امر
انهم يروحوا للجنرال وقتها بيفتكروا ان
عندهم ماموريه عاديه لكنهم بيروحوا
بالمهمه ايه اللي حصل ببساطه الاستطلاع
الجوي لاحظ ان الجيش الالماني اللي كان
انسحب من قطاع الجبهه الغربيه في شمال
فرنسا ما انسحبش بس تراجع بشكل استراتيجي
لخط على الحدود في انتظار البريطانيين
انهم يهاجموا علشان يقضوا عليهم
بالمدفعيات في الخنادق كل ده بيسمعوا
ابطال القصه سكوفي
بيسمعوا ده في حاله صدمه لان الكتيبه اللي
هتتهاجم هيموتوا كلهم علشان ده فخ وعايز
اقول لك ان بليك اخوه ملازم في الكتيبه دي
فكان عنده دافع عاطفي جدا يروح علشان ينقذ
اخوه بيامر الجنرال ايرون الجنديين
بنقل رساله للعقيد مكانزي من الكتيبه
التانيه
والرساله فيها قرار من القياده العسكريه
بالغاء هجوم مقرر في صباح اليوم التالي
بيبدا يتحرك
للمنطقه المحرمه وصولا للخنادق الالمانيه
المهجوره لكن سكوفيلد بيتصب في ايديه
اليسرى خلال عبورهم ولما بينزلوا في تكنات
تحت الارض بيكتشفوا وجود سلك متفجر عملوه
الالمان وبمجرد ما يدوس عليه فار بينفجر
في المكان لدرجه كانت هتتسبب فيلد
بينجح في انقاذه وبيوصلوا المزرعه مهجوره
وخلال وجودهم هناك بتسقط طائره المانيه
خلال معركه مع طائرات الحلفاء
التيار ووقت ما يسكوفيلد بيقول له رحمه
اننا نقتله بيرفض وبيحاول يقنعه يروح يجيب
ميه وبالفعل عمل ده لكن خلال لحظه كان
الالماني غدر ببليك وطعنه بشده فاطلق عليه
سكوفيلد النار للاسف المشهد اللي بعد ده
مؤثر جدا وهيعلق في ذاكرتك الفتره هتشوف
بليك اللي كان رايح يوصل رساله لاخوه
وبيخاطر بحياته علشان يوصل بتشوفه وهو
بيحتضر وبيبدا يتكلم مع سكوفيلد ويقول له
اوعدني ان انت تكمل المهمه قل لامي ان انا
كنت شجاع بيوعدوا سكوفيلد وبيموت بريك
وبيدخل في حاله صدمه ان صديقه العزيز مات
بياخد سكوفيلد خواتم بلايك والرساله
وبيحاول ينقلوا من مكان تاني لكنه مش
بيقدر وقتها هيوصل جنود من كتيبه تانيه
وصلوا لما شافوا انفجار الطياره
وجهته وقتها بيعرض عليه ان هو يكمل معه
لكن للاسف بعد ما ركب معاهم بيمنعهم جسر
متدمر بالقرب من
انهم يكملوا وقتها بيختار عنهم وبيستغل
الوقت اللي باقي في عبوره لوحده لكنه
للاسف بيتعرض لاطلاق نار من قناص وخلال
تبادل الطلقات بيصاب وبيفقد وعيه وبيصحى
وبيبدا يشق طريقه عبر انقاض المدينه
المضيئه وخلال عبوره بيقابل امراه فرنسيه
مختبئه مع طفل رضيع وبتساعد سكوفيلد في
علاج جروحه بتعرفه على طفلتها الرضيعه
وتسكن فيلد بيطلع كل الاكل واللبن اللي
معه وبيسيبهم وبيمشي
خلال هروبه من النفق بيواجه جندي الماني
وبيقدر يقضي عليه ويهرب بالقفز في النهر
في النهايه بيوصل للناحيه التانيه وبيلاقي
مجموعه من الجنود بيغنوا وبيسالوه فين
وجهته فبيقول لهم ان هو عايز يوصل للعقيد
مكانزي بيقولوا له احنا الكتيبه دي بس
الفرقه رقم اربعه وقتها كانت بدات الفرقه
رقم واحد بالهجوم بيبدا يجري في الخندق
لكنه كان زحمه جدا وكل دقيقه بيتاخرها في
عدد كبير جدا بيموت وقتها بياخد القرار
الاصعب وبيطلع في ساحه المعركه المفتوحه
الموازيه لخط الخندق البريطاني فبيبدا
الهجوم عليه وبيبدا يجلس كوفيلد باقصى
سرعته علشان يوصل للجنرال ما كنزي
لما بيقول له الرساله الجنرال بيرفض يسحب
جنوده بس لما بيصر عليه يقراها بيسحب
الجنود على الفور بعدها بيبدا يدور على
اخوبليك وبيوصل له الرساله وبيحكي له قد
ايه كان شجاع بينتهي الفيلم بسكوفيلد وهو
بيمشي في مكان كل خضره وبيركن على الشجره
وبتكون هي دي النهايه اما بقى عمال وراء
فيلم 19 الفيلم نازل سنه 2019 من اخراج
وانتاج سمندز واللي شارك في كتابه الفيلم
مع كريستي ويلسون الفيلم مستوحى الجزئيا
من القصص اللي رواها جدو لابو الفريدمنز
عن خدمته خلال الحرب العالميه الاولى تم
الاعلانها للمشروع في يونيو سنه 2018 مع
توقيع مكاي وتشاب انف اكتوبر وانضم بقيه
الممثلين في مارس تم التصوير في المملكه
المتحده المصور السينمائي
اضواء طويل جدا لعرض الفيلم باكمله على
شكل لقطتين متتاليتين تم عرضه لاول مره في
المملكه المتحده في اربعه ديسمبر سنه 2019
وتم اصداره مسرحيا في الولايات المتحده في
25 ديسمبر ب
وفي المملكه المتحده في عشره يناير سنه
2020 بواسطه
التذاكر وبلغ اجمالي ارباحه 384 مليون
دولار في جميع انحاء العالم اترشح الفيلم
العشر جوائز في حفله توزيع جوائز الاوسكار
الاثنين وفاز بثلاث جوائز وجوائز تانيه
كتير الحقيقه ان فيلم 19 مهما احكي لك عنه
عن الاحداث اللي وراه مش هيكون كفايه
محتاج تشوفه بنفسك وتستمتع بقصته اللي مش
هتنساها شوف الفيلم دلوقتي واستناني
الحلقه اللي جايه في فيلم جديد من بودكارا
الافلام المقدمه للعربيه
[موسيقى]